the Pittsburgh Science and Technology
Academy is a brand new Pittsburgh public
school serving 250 students in grades 6
through 9 and growing to serve 550
students in grades 6 through 12 school
is originally designed as a system of
synthesis project at Heinz College at
Carnegie Mellon University in
partnership with Pittsburgh Public
Schools our goal with our systems
project was to design a school that
would be capable of taking students
entering at a wide range of ability
levels and connect them to advanced
coursework in science technology
engineering and math before graduation
and connect them to a real opportunity
after graduation something specific
rather than leaving it to chance and
hoping they were well enough prepared
that they would find their own
opportunity we wanted to build systems
into the school that would make sure
that every student graduated knowing
what their next step would be the unique
thing about the Heinz College program
and one of the things that attracted me
to it was the fact that instead of
culminating in master's thesis in
research that might just go somewhere
sit on a shelf and never be utilized the
program culminates in something very
real a consulting project and so 10 of
us 10 students worked with Pittsburgh
Public Schools as our client to develop
the science and technology
to me that was in that started in August
2006 it is now fall 2009 and the school
was a reality so I was a project manager
of one of the two project managers of
the Heinz College team and when I
graduated from high ins in 2007 I was
hired by Pittsburgh Public Schools to
continue the management of the project
and open the school the new curriculum
that we've introduced is called dream
with discovered design so students
learned to set goals generate hypotheses
ask questions they learned to do
research and then they learned to apply
that research that creations things that
are tangible that they can touch that
they can share this curriculum is going
to grow over time so it's not right now
what we think it will be in a few years
but we think that it's it's very
attractive to students and it's a very
hands-on way to get them connected to
these fields it's pretty amazing
I've been involved I've been involved on
a lot of projects usually they don't
follow through they're not implemented
completely it's a lot to ask of a of a
giant project to have it three years
later be something that's actually
powerful to think that only three years
ago we or three years ago today we're
you know just in the middle of the
design of this school had no idea what
it would look like even at the end of
that semester let alone to think that
three years later we could be walking
these halls and talking to kids who are
actually at this school it's pretty I
think that
and as a nation we have a responsibility
to realign our education system with our
economy and with economic opportunities
of our future as students want to
participate in these fields but they
need to be made accessible to them you
know and the message that we shared with
students was not we need you to come to
this school so that we can be
economically competitive as a nation the
message when we share with them is
science technology engineering math can
be fun can be hands-on here's what it
looks like
and through these fields you can make a
good living but you can also do
something even more powerful which is
you can make a difference in your
community and in your world